في الخامس والعشرين من يوليو من العام
الماضي اقل رئيس التونسي قيس سعيد حكومه
هشام المشيشي وعلق عمل البرلمان وهو
معتبرته احزاب وشخصيه المعارضه انقلاب على
الثوره والدستور في سبتمبر ايلول من العام
نفسه اصدر السعيد امرا رئاسيا يتضمن
التدابير استثنائيه اخرى تعزيز صلاحيته
وابقى على توطئه دستور 2014 وبدي الحقوق
والحريات تشكل طيف واسع رافض لقرارات سعيد
ضمه تنسيقيه الاحزاب الديمقراطيه اجتماعيه
ومبادره مواطنون ضد الانقلاب كما عرض
قرارات الصعيد لاحقا الحزب الدستوري الحر
واحزاب الاخرى اعلن الصعيد خريطه طريق
تتضمن اجراء استفتاء الكتروني لاصلاح
النظام السياسي واستفتاء على الدستور
وانتخابات تشريعيه
ووسطهامات للسيد باستعمال قوانين قمعيه ضد
منتقل قراراته اذا دعاه السفراء الدول
الاعضاء في مجموعه السبع المعتمدون في
تونس الى عوده سريعه لعمل المؤسسات خرافيه
في البلاد بدايه الشباط فبراير الماضي
اعلن الصعيد حل المجلس الاعلى للقضاء وهو
هيئه مستقله ولحقها نهايه مارس حله
البرلمان ثم قام في ابريل بتغيير قانون
هيئه الانتخابات ومنح نفسه سلطه التعيين
رئيسها واعضاء من مجلسها وفي ابريل الماضي
شكلت هيئه لتسير جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه
المعارضه وتضم 10 قوى سياسيه ومبادره
مواطرون اذا الانقلاب ونظم التحركات
ومظاهره تدعو للعوده الى المسار
الديمقراطيه في العشرين من ايار ما يعين
الصعيد استاذ القانون الدستوري الصادق
بالعيد على راسي لجنه مهمتها اعدادات
دستور للجمهوريه الجديده لكن سعيد وبعد ما
تسلم مشروع اللجنه اصدر نسخه اخرى للدستور
وعرضه على الاستفتاء امتنع نحو 70% من
الناخبين عن المشاركه في الاستفتاء الذي
اقر الدستور الجديد ومنح صلاحيه واسعه
لرئيس الدوله في حين خلص من صلاحيه
البرلمان التشريعيه والرقانيه
صفا سبتمبر ايلول اصدر سعيد قانونا
انتخابات جديده يعتمدوا نظام الاقتراع على
الافراد على دورتين بدلا من نظام القوائم
واعلنت غالبيه واحزاب المعارضه مقاطعتها
للانتخابات
تواصلت تونس شهر اكتوبر الى اتفاق على
مستوى الخبراء مع صندوق النقد الدولي بشان
حزمه انقاذ بنحو مليار و900 مليون دولار
ما زالت تحوم حولها غيوم من الشك اتفاق
مقابل اصلاحات اقتصاديه لا تحظى شعبيه في
وقت ارتفع فيه الدين العام التونسي الى
اكثر من 35 مليار دولار ما يشكل اكثر من
80% من الناتج المحليه الاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل حذر الحكومه والسعيده من
الاستمرار فيما وصفها بسياسه الارتجال
والتعنت والانسداد كما اعلن معارضته
للانتخابات التشريعيه المقرره واعتبرها
بلا رائحه بلا لون انتخابات تمت مقطاعتها
بشكل كبير اذ بلغت نسبه المشاركه نحو 11%
السعيد فيها فرصه تاريخيه تغيير بينما
اعتبرتها المعارضه اخفاقا كبيره لمسار
الرئيس داعيه لرحيله بعد هذا الاختبار